now you were a part of uh the jump which
was one of my favorite NBA shows of the
I mean probably since I've been an adult
because it reminds me of like
it just reminded me like when I was a
kid there was like dope NBA shows like
inside stuff but you know different
images it didn't feel like a generic NBA
show and um obviously uh you know you
guys brought uh Rachel over to Showtime
sports which is where you guys have your
podcast you had her on the show you guys
had her back what that going through
that situation and kind of seeing your
friend go through a situation in which
you know the cancel culture [ __ ] kind of
rears its head and their context gets
thrown out the window Nuance gets thrown
out the window yeah I mean it's it's
just unfortunate because you know you
you're in the business in the business
it's a dirty business you know what I
mean and when you kind of know when you
find out what happened
it's just like oh [ __ ] damn you know and
then there's proof of that's how it
happened but it still got played out a
whole nother way just like damn that's
you know it's it's a cold game but you
know for any of you guys go check out
that Rachel Nichols episode on uh all
the smoke on Showtime YouTube and it
it'll just kind of show you have you
guys cut a lot out too okay am I wrong
because it was kind of short yeah no it
was it was yeah it was crazy because you
know obviously you know my thing is you
know I'm also employed by dealers you're
on both sides so it's not like I'm ever
going to play a corporate type role but
if it's just like I can't uh show that
I'm like on like hosting I can't let you
just throw certain people on yeah yeah
because that makes sense
on me so I'm you know I'm Gonna Keep it
busy but I'm also gonna keep it real and
I had a lot of love for Rachel you know
what I mean but you know what was crazy
was I had to talk to some ESPN people
after that and it wasn't nothing like
crazy
um it was just more you know kind of
give us a heads up but I felt like you
know if if Ray Rachel's truth of her
telling her truth on my show was going
to cost me my job there I would have
took that right because that's how to me
how dope she was how opening she was how
how important an instrumental she was to
me and stack in particular but guys like
T-Mac Paul all these people that she
really kind of just really showed us the
ropes on that on that jump show you know
what I mean so once I found out like
what really happened I was just like
damn this is this is sticky but at the
same time like I feel like I got to let
my sister talk and it was gonna cost me
money which was dope which was dope
because a lot of people wouldn't do that
yeah if it's gonna cost me my job it's
gonna cost me my job but you know to me
her truth is important because she's a
good person you know I mean so we're
definitely happy to have her over at you
know uh Showtime now which is dope you
know we're continuing to build a
beautiful little ecosystem over there
with her Kevin Garnett Paul Pierce you
know myself that's great
you know we got guys coming in and out
so we got a T-Mac so we got AI we got a
lot of cool little like I said like if
if if
uh companies play like pick up games
with like talent I like our [ __ ] would
be over like we got you guys got all
these Hall of Famers it would be crazy
yeah if you guys actually like yeah
I'm gonna play on the showtime so ESPN
you know first Showtime or fox or
whatever it was so you know it's a
purple average Five Points a game for
ESPN I don't even know if perk can get
up and down the court bigfo he you know
he just tore his quad from slipping and
everything so he's he's getting healed
up but I don't know if her got any any
points in